[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 9 avril bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
le point déjà sur la propagation du
coronavirus dans le département la
pandémie toujours sur une pente
ascendante et 219 personnes sont
décédées dans les hôpitaux du
département d'après les dernières
données de santé publique france et dix
décès supplémentaires donc entre mardi
et mercredi
mille quarante personnes étaient
hospitalisées hier sur le sol yvelinois
193 placé en réanimation sont
enregistrés également 598 retour à
domicile de patients dont l'état de
santé s'est amélioré
un chiffre en constante augmentation
outre le personnel hospitalier les
médecins et praticiens libéraux sont
également pleinement engagé dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire et des
professionnels qui exercent parfois au
sein de maisons médicales pour les
accompagner durant cette période où ils
ont ralenti voire cesser leurs activités
le conseil départemental des yvelines a
créé une aide exceptionnelle une
enveloppe de 250 mille euros pour la
gratuité des loyers dans 15 sites du
territoire est la participation sera à
verser aux collectivités propriétaires
des maisons médicales pour compenser
cette gratuité face à l'épidémie de
covin 19 les actions de solidarité sont
nombreuses dans les yvelines
exemple à coignières avec une concession
automobile qui propose de réparer les
voitures des soignants à tarif réduit
est les détails avec ce sujet d'aurélie
rond et de patrick jacques de dixmude et
soignants
avec la terrière de casser et
aujourd'hui on est en train de faire un
véhicule qui a été accidenté et sur
lequel on a fait une expertise à
distance spécialisée dans la voiture
sans permis ce groupe a dû stopper son
activité commerciale dans les huit
concessions d'île de france en raison de
la crise sanitaire
seule la permanence atelier mécanique à
coignières a été conservé une offre
particulière pour le personnel soignant
a été mise en place fin mars
on a dû tout simplement qu'on allait
donc bien vite et bien évidemment ouvrir
l'activité aux voitures sans permis et
aux voitures traditionnelles parce qu'on
sait faire
les pièces détachées à prix coûtant la
main d'oeuvre avec une remise à 10%
si les véhicules ne pouvais pas rouler
on faisait le transport à prix coûtant
aussi huit salariés travaillent
habituellement sur ce site
aujourd'hui ils ne sont que trois en
activité
tous portent des combinaisons des
masques et des gants afin de respecter
les règles sanitaires
on a mis aussi en place plus de
protection au sein des véhicules des
clients d ou sur les sièges ou ce volant
ou ce levier de vitesse ou ce frein à
main mise à disposition des clés dans le
véhicule zéro contact avec le client
tous les types de règlement chèque
espèces ou carte bancaire sont acceptés
et on désinfecte bien évidemment aussi
le tpe si le confinement se poursuit
jusqu'à fin avril ce dirigeant a estimé
une perte de 6 cents mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires pour son groupe
ils continuent malgré tout à proposer
cette offre de solidarité aux personnels
soignants mais aussi au personnel de la
grande distribution
autre initiative solidaire celle de la
plateforme value mycar dont le siège est
basé au vésinet ce moteur de recherche
permet à un automobiliste de trouver un
prestataire pour l'entretien ou la
réparation de son véhicule en quelques
clics le site a décidé pour les
prochaines semaines de rendre gratuit
l'ensemble de ses services le prix des
interventions sera directement fixé
entre le particulier est le prestataire
objectif assurer l'entretien des
véhicules des personnels soignants et de
ceux qui continuent à travailler
mais aussi favoriser de l'autre côté la
rémunération des indépendants dans un
contexte où beaucoup de garage sont
fermés écoutez les explications du
fondateur de value my car on s'est posé
la question de ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour participer pour aider à l'effort
global du pays face à cette situation
que l'on est en train de traverser on
s'est demandé ce que l'on pouvait faire
et on a constaté que l'essentiel des
garages en france aujourd'hui soit
fermées soit parce qu'ils ont passé
d'activité soit parce que ils n'ont plus
de pièces ce qui fait que tous les
personnels de santé les personnes de la
grande distribution et toutes les
personnes qui continuent à travailler
soit pour nous défendre contre le virus
soit pour nous permettre de continuer à
vivre
bah non plus solution lorsqu'ils ont
besoin de quelqu'un pour dépanner ou
entretenir leur véhicule et donc du coup
on a décidé de mettre à disposition la
plateforme de manière complètement
gratuite de manière à permettre à toutes
ces personnes qui continuent à
travailler de trouver des solutions en
urgence proche de chez eux
solidaires vous pouvez l'être également
en verve aux agriculteurs ceux qui sont
autour de chez vous en favorisant
notamment les circuits courts à saint
quentin en yvelines où par exemple
treize des seize amap sont restées
ouvertes l'agglomération a mis en place
une page dédiée pour favoriser le manger
local vous y trouverez l'ensemble des
producteurs autour de chez vous et des
initiatives proposées en cette période
de confinement comme la distribution de
paniers pour rappel une carte
interactive a été lancé pour trouver
très facilement ses producteurs et mais
aussi l'ensemble des commerces toujours
en activité une inscription est
d'ailleurs possible pour se faire
connaître des consommateurs mais malgré
ces initiatives que l'on voit fleurir
partout dans les yvelines et en france
la crise va être sans précédent
la france devrait faire face à la pire
récession de son histoire depuis 1945
est d'après les mots du ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire et
l'estimation de la banque de france
semblent aller dans ce sens le produit
intérieur brut a chuté de 6% au premier
trimestre 2009 un chiffre confirmé par
une étude adressée au gouvernement par
jean-noël barrot le député des yvelines
s'est penché sur les effets du
confinement sur l'activité des
différents secteurs de l'économie
nicolas landry l'a interrogé bonjour
jean noël barrot
bonjour député de la 2e circonscription
des yvelines 10 président de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale alors première chose la banque
de france estime la baisse du pib au
premier trimestre 2 6%
c'est du jamais vu depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est confirmé
la france entre dans une récession pour
cette année 2020
mais alors une réception en principe on
la qualifie à partir de deux trimestres
de croissance négative
ce chiffre de 6 % et pas très étonnant
puisque vous savez que la semaine
dernière
l'insee et d'autres instituts de
statistiques on essayé d'estimer la
baisse d'activité que nous connaissons
depuis la prise des mesures de
confinement et qu'ils avaient estimé à
près de 35 % la baisse d'activité sur
les 15 derniers dernière ce les quinze
derniers jours du mois de mars
donc cette ce chiffre 2 de l'unsa et de
la banque de france n'est pas très
étonnant on peut s'attendre évidemment
un chiffre beaucoup plus important pour
le deuxième trimestre puisque c'est le
deuxième trimestre qui sera impacté
complètement et de plein fouet par cette
crise
de nouvelles mesures devront être prises
par bercy
écoutez il faut d'abord rappeler que le
plan de soutien à l'économie aux
entreprises aux associations aux
salariés aux indépendants par le
gouvernement sur la décision du
président de la république est inédit
dans son ampleur l'extension du chômage
partiel pour les entreprises et pour les
salariés n'a pas d'équivalent historique
les les prêts garantis aux entreprises
constitue un enfin on constitue une
aporie dire qui est 50 fois plus
important que ce qui avait été mis en
place pour la crise de 2008
maintenant il ya des ajustements qui se
font au fil de l'eau sur ces mesures
d'urgence à mesure que les difficultés
rencontrées par les entreprises sont
remontés y compris par les
parlementaires au ministère de
l'économie des finances et il ya des
ajustements qui sont en cours mais
évidemment qu'il y aura d'autres mesures
de soutien à mettre en oeuvre notamment
pour continuer d'accompagner les
entreprises et notamment les plus
petites et plus fragiles et puis ensuite
dans un second temps pour préparer la
relance de l'économie dans votre
circonscription retrouve plusieurs zones
d'activité à la fois l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc avec de
l'industrie dur de la recherche et du
développement
mais vous êtes aussi aux portes du du
plateau de saclay zone aussi industriel
quel retour vous avez de ses pôles
d'activité et des chefs d'entreprise qui
se situe sur ses pôles d'activité
écoutez dans les grandes entreprises du
secteur de vélizy du secteur de
saint-quentin les entreprises ce sont
les grandes entreprises les grands
groupes se sont organisés pour
poursuivre leur production en
télétravail notamment quitte pour
certaines à arrêter leur production
c'est le cas d'airbus qui s'est arrêtée
une grosse semaine de manière à
réorganiser ses systèmes et ses jeux
télé chaîne de production afin de
respecter les consignes sanitaires
en revanche pour toutes les petites
entreprises du commerce et de la vente
des difficultés très grande et donc on
est à leurs côtés pour pour essayer de
les accompagner dans la mobilisation des
dispositifs mis en place par l'état et
par les banques de manière à ce qu'elles
puissent être préservés des difficultés
qu'on est en train de traverser
dernière question jean noël barrot
craignez vous des défaillances
d'entreprises des fermetures des dépôts
de bilan écoutez tout est mis en oeuvre
pour permettre aux entreprises de de
survivre à cette crise
vous le savez une entreprise c'est c'est
un capital social relationnel
organisationnel donc quand tu ne fais
une entreprise ferme c'est tout
toute cette richesse qui est qui est
détruite et puis quand à quand un
commerce de proximité dans un dans un
village dans un bourg ferme et bien
c'est un peu l'âme du village qu'on
étouffe donc il faut que collectivement
on s'assure qu'aucune entreprise ne soit
amené à fermer mais il va y avoir
évidemment les difficultés très grande
donc on sera là au côté des entreprises
pour les aider à surmonter ces
difficultés là merci jean noël barrot
merci à vous
la situation qui risque d'être
préjudiciable également pour les
chocolatiers dont l'essentiel du chiffre
d'affaires se fait au moment des fêtes
de pâques mais certains s'organisent
tout de même à gimont iii du passage des
cloches aurélie rose et patrick jacques
de dixmude se sont rendus dans une
enseigne de guyancourt qui propose la
livraison à domicile
rassurez-vous malgré la situation
actuelle les enfants et les grands
enfants ne manqueront pas de chocolat
cette année à pâques dans sa toute
nouvelle boutique à guyancourt le
chocolatier nicolas et lewin a dû
modifier son organisation
il propose aux clients de saint quentin
en yvelines un service de livraison pac
représente 20% de son chiffre d'affaires
à cette solution va lui permettre de le
sauvegarder
nous les chocolatiers artisanaux on a eu
très peur et au final on a quand même
ravi de constater que depuis le début de
la semaine on a beaucoup de commandes
que les clients les clients amateurs de
chocolats fins sont au rendez vous et
donc on se retrouve pour être tout à
fait franc complètement submergé pour la
fin de semaine en raison du confinement
seuls trois salariés sur dix sont
présents
concernant les sujets en chocolat on
retrouve des grands classiques comme les
oeufs ou les poules mais aussi des
créations plus insolites
cette année on a voulu travailler sur
les joues et donc on a fait de jouer en
montage un jouet en forme de cheval à
bascule et un autre en forme de diabolo
cinq sortes de chocolats sont utilisés
du plus traditionnel au plus original un
chocolat à base de framboise et un
chocolat à base de fruits de la passion
qui nous permet à la fois de faire les
petites touches de couleurs qu'on peut
retrouver sur les sur le nez ou les
ailes des poules
ça nous permet de colorer mais sans
colorants artificiels parce qu'on est
100% en colorant naturel de fruits la
boutique qui propose également des
viennoiseries et de la pâtisserie met en
place son service de livraison à
domicile jusqu'à la fin du confinement
un mot de sport avant de refermer cette
émission cela ne faisait aucun doute
mais l'officialisation est arrivé hier
le semi-marathon de trappes est annulée
est la troisième édition devait se tenir
le 26 avril prochain au programme de
l'événement également était prévue une
course de 10 km est la mairie a confirmé
que la totalité des frais engagés par
les participants seraient remboursés et
des remboursements effectués dans les
prochains jours via virement bancaire ou
auprès de la direction des sports une
fois le confinement levées le
semi-marathon reviendra à trappes en
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de votre fidélité on se quitte sur
ces images l'élan de générosité
culinaire initiée par le chef jean
christophe broux 10 et grossi dans le
département cette semaine le restaurant
la bella vita de coignières a fait
livrer gratuitement des pizzas aux
pompiers de maurepas et les soldats du
feu ont même eu le droit à une
confection en direct de desserts restez
chez vous et très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à